[Music]
hey you guys and thanks for tuning into
eg live I'm Katie Krauss and Mandy TV is
here who is of course one of the EPS of
13 reasons why season 2 streaming now
you're also Selena Gomez's mom and this
is kind of your guys's brainchild and
baby from season 1 so why was it
important for you to continue telling
the story with season 2 well I felt
there was a lot more to explore and
there were a lot of answers and the
feedback that we received we realized
that people were really yearning for
this type of conversation and that there
was a lot of places to explore more of
the social issues that are currently
happening and so why you know why leave
it if we can continue creating the
conversation yeah talk about some of
those issues and what conversations that
you've seen sparked online through this
season so far
I actually don't read online coming
really yeah I do that um I just I prefer
to have conversations with people so I
randomly like talk to people and it's
very it's very strange but I just feel
sometimes like I'll read on my Instagram
and things like that but I I don't
really kind of go to different places
because if if the content just seems
like it's a little off it's like okay
you're missing the point and you're
shutting down the conversation that
these kids are wanting to have so you
it's over it could be a reverse effect
of oh I feel like we're trying to
achieve yeah when they get it's almost
like don't talk about this don't talk
about this and now you're redoing a read
recluse and now the kids are afraid to
talk because it's been you know shame
yeah that it happened so it's just so
sad to know in a lot of ways it's kind
of dumbfounding to me and I don't know
if it's because I'm so into psychology
and that that I'm always curious mm-hmm
and I talk to anybody and it was like
you're gonna get robbed or attacked one
day you just like stop and talk to
everybody and want to know why they're
doing this and why they're doing that
and I'm like I don't know it's just
something that kind of is and always on
my mind
so it's intriguing yeah it's intriguing
to me I don't I don't judge I don't care
I just like want to know why you know
I had to cancel and shut down my
Facebook during the campaign because I
was literally on there all the time
curious okay well why yeah like you're
like more than you know some like random
statement yeah why do you feel this way
and I was like oh gosh
that was my first first time on social
media ever and I closed the account
within like a month because I was like
I'm too curious yeah and you'd be going
through I would go through a lane I
would I go through if I did that all the
time but I do go through my my Instagram
something okay yeah he responding to
something yeah I think it's nice that
they feel that connected to you and that
they can't ask you questions and that
you do respond a lot and a lot of people
don't do that so yeah I think that's
great
by the way if you guys are just now
tuning in Mandy TV is here send your
questions in will get them right here on
this iPad I do want to ask you a season
two there was no book to go off of did
that make it more challenging for you
guys to put together this season and to
dictate where the story was gonna go
well you know that's really all Brian
your key you know it was it definitely
they worked and put it together and you
know they kind of bring it and you know
propose this is this is their idea and
he's just like I'm in the writing team
were so amazing there's just really no
you know no need to kind of second guess
where he's going and so it was just kind
of like really what are the topics that
would be relevant and would make sense
and that are pertinent to this time that
is what we kind of had you know really
looked in I think for the end product
right you know I wasn't in that that
that's his brainchild okay yeah I'm
curious I know that you and Selena have
both been very vocal about how close to
home this project was for both of you
how do you think this show would have
impacted your younger self and also
Selena's younger self um that's a good
question I I wish that there because I
actually talked about this in in a
different interview I actually sat
Selena in front of intervention and we
watched a couple episodes because there
was a lot of drug addiction
that ran through my family and not my
but my parents are like that but you
know through my family that I witnessed
as a kid growing up and that that to me
being in it I saw it and I think you
either go one way or the other like it's
something that a you know you've
rebelled with or you've seen it so you
don't want to go down that Lane and I
never went down that Lane because of
that and you know because I was around
it and so because interventions a little
hardcore so it's like something you have
to monitor and then like kind of talk
about yeah but anything was like I I
can't recall anything that wasn't this
bubblegum that wasn't a bubblegum kind
of promising world yeah and I just I
wish that I would have had something
instead of like oh I've been they're
coming to me kind of thing because I
don't think kids really believed their
parents that's all kids yeah you know
yeah they're just like okay yeah
whatever you didn't you've never were
young you're always old so how old was
Celina when you made her watch those
episodes of intervention I think 11 was
she terrified do you think it worked do
you think it instilled some sort of I
don't I don't know I hope I mean she
wasn't scared when it was happening so
maybe it like did or didn't but she kind
of understood what I was like saying you
know and I would scream parts and like
we had fast-forward so or like I'd let
her see certain things but you know like
the conversations and the actual
interventions and what it's done and
stuff that that's what I did yeah as a
mom like you're so open and genuine it
seems like especially with wanting to
take on this project but there's a lot
of parents that are calling for Netflix
to take down this show and there's a lot
of parents who don't want their kids to
watch 13 reasons why how do you respond
to them um
well I wouldn't tell anybody really how
to parent their child and that's up to
them it's a feel that we gave it as a
platform and a tool to be dialogue
because I use this kind of a comparison
a lot on the documentary bully that was
made years
go I feel like kids who went to see that
documentary I already don't like
bullying so you have to kind of put it
into a way that the kids that aren't
gonna really realize what they're
getting into I don't think a lot of them
knew it's gonna be such a conversation
starter and you saw you know like
letters going home you know to parents
and like their kid probably already saw
the show so and it's like kinda I think
almost made a connection whether they
wanted to make it or not you know and
and or they they weren't aware so the
fact that we're talking about it and it
was it was so talked about and I that's
that was our goal yeah it's it's it's
something that's been looming over our
society for so long and it has went up
sixty percent in the last like forty
five years and I just filled with so sad
it's so sad and you know it's there's no
way to exactly predict someone that's
going to do that and I think we all wore
a camera all day long we would catch
probably 20 things that we do that's
kind of crappy to somebody and we don't
mean for it to be so you feel like this
show holds up a mere almost yeah just
like through a reflection yeah III think
that that's great storytelling in
general is that's like I think that's
why animations work so well because it's
a fantasy land but the writers and the
directors they they keep it to the heart
yeah and I that's why everybody goes to
them it's because of that we were
talking earlier and we had one of the
cast members in here a couple days ago
there is a scene this season it's in the
last episode and it involves Tyler in a
bathroom and he gets
sodomized how do you respond to people
who cannot believe that that scene is in
this show I would just suggest that they
Google veneers that eventually happened
that it happens yeah yeah there's
nothing there's nothing that anybody
ever has put or had the desire in our
group to make anything gratuitous or
shock value
it's like it's shocking it's horrific
but it's happening yeah and I mean
there's videos you know that people post
and that's online forever and so it's a
it's a just say the the culture sure you
know so you just look it up and then
educate yourself that you know you need
to look out for this what about in the
finale there's this is a spoiler alert
for anyone who's watching but it ends
with the an almost school shooting and
clay of course prevents it from
happening that seems so reflective of
what is going on right now most recently
with Houston how do you how do you talk
about that and the realness of the show
in that regard you know when I was
thinking about that first of all in in
the morning when I saw that it was I
felt oh my gosh this is hopeless there's
been more school shootings than the
years of our yeah you know it's like 22
only 20 weeks of the year and what I
really think this show besides that
scene should they that I I really liked
is mr. Porter I feel like first season
people kind of like felt that we and
this is my opinion people felt like we
weren't giving the fair shot to school
counselors and we were putting blame on
them and but if you really really really
watch and pay attention to that
character he came from a school that
people were dying so when you come in
and you say pants he's like I don't know
what that means
yes like and and so was he supplied with
the tools he needed to transfer to a
different like culture or did the system
fell them and so I feel like instead of
like for instance and I'm not gonna like
get political here but for instance LA
they're they're trying to build that 3.5
billion dollar prison right so the
biggest one in the world so why are we
not taking some of that money and
allocating and into the school system to
prevent
filling up that prison right because
then the goal is gonna be to fill the
prison so I feel like if you put the
money into the education the educators
and take care of the people who are
taking care of our kids that's that's
where you see
yes mr. Porter cared but where was he
what was he really supposed to do and to
that regard I almost feel like he didn't
realize the impact that he would have on
these right students and I think it
would be so beneficial for counselors to
watch this show so that they don't make
the same well you know it's not even you
know it's not even necessarily like I
don't know
yeah his phone rang it's like it's the I
think I think we all can miss a sign
yeah and that's the point
and so you don't you don't you know I
don't want to put it wasn't putting
blame on it's like there was two
counselors in that entire school and
then he has he does have his own kid and
wife and the phone ring and but like of
course like yeah it was true it's like
if you don't tell me I don't know what
I'm supposed to do his hands are tied
and so then the phone rings and life
happens and then unfortunately
everybody's just it's just such a
fast-paced I'm good it's that's the
importance of just like you know kind of
paying attention yeah changing gears a
little bit I know that you actually
acted in the past oh my gosh did you I
don't think I officially like four plays
yeah did you ever think about putting
yourself in this series and playing
maybe the role of a boss no question oh
no I woulda tore this up no I have no
skill and no skill at all well you do
have your own production company they
kicked to the curb production so I'm
curious what other shows or I know we
were talking earlier about a documentary
like what else do you want to explore
aside from 13 reasons why um well we we
have we do have the documentary like
it's like a docu-series kind of thing
that explores the world of nature versus
nurture and in it is kind of following a
little bit of where I came from
the difference in how you branch out and
like kind of just the different ways of
making decisions and how different
elements of my life affected my
decisions to see okay why am I here
right now at my age still questioning
Who I am and where I you know why I make
the decisions I do and so then we also
have a couple of other books that were
or adapting we're currently adapting and
they're I I basically only other one we
only have one otherwise the rest is
older content so it's just about it has
to have some kind of message to it
without being preachy and it just has to
mean something I don't know it for me
it's all about the story so that's why
there's not tons of content we're so
slow and I'm have a problem with being
perfect like perfect yeah it's like
that's why there's like not tons of
content but we were in development like
in different levels and hopefully we can
announce some of them like really soon
because I'm really excited about you
well we know what the why a novel is is
it well yes it wasn't here Times
bestseller okay yeah when can we expect
an announcement hopefully next month
how about yeah yeah well we ever see
Selina in one of the projects I mean the
ones on my slate now know I don't know
where she would fit but no not like but
I don't know I mean I can't say no and
then sure you know I feel like you have
given up
you had Selena very young you were 16
years old and you really dedicated your
life to her career in many ways to know
now and to see her be one of the most
famous stars in the world what is that
like I don't I don't know I mean it's
it's it's to me when you're here in LA
we're in a bubble yeah so it doesn't
seem weird until I'm out like in
Wisconsin or something and someone like
in line is talking about her and like
knows what
war or where she was and I had no clue
you know what I mean it's like it she's
an adult and so people will ask me when
they ask me questions and I don't know
because we don't talk about that you
know it that's when I think it's weird
sure because I'm like okay that's that's
a super weird thing because it's just
normal out here you know that this is
what most people do and I don't know so
it's it's kind of um is I'm extremely
proud of her and all the hard work that
she did and you know and and where she's
done and the choices that she's made
it's just it's you know it's your kid
it's hard to explain really like I don't
look at her as superhuman and it's funny
because like Joey King I mean when they
just remember business I see her kissing
a guy in that new Netflix show I'm going
what's happening like like and when
there's so little when you watch them
grow up like and you know he had his
single out I was like Jaime and I'm
going oh wait a minute this is really
awkward because I've known you since you
were like 14 but you're not singing
about and he's ripped now no I got
ripped it he's a man and I'm gonna know
so it's really it's kind of like I think
you get stuck in a time warp
right obviously Selena has been very
vocal and and candid about her health
struggles she recently had a kidney
transplant for you as her mom what was
that like and how difficult was that for
you that was probably be one of the
hardest things to ever experience and as
a parent and especially when there was
complications and it was just me and her
you know and she had to go in and it was
yeah it was um I was not only carrying
first the weight of the mother but also
I felt the weight for like France yeah
and her mother and her family and you
know I I think I'm banned from Cedars
just I went to both sides of the towel
for some reason they were like in
different towers and I was just like
every little thing like I was monitoring
and like yelling and freaking out but it
was um it was pretty deep it was pretty
rough like so
god bless any of the families that have
kids that have ongoing illnesses because
I the strength that those families have
is insane because that was just I mean
she will always have lupus but yeah you
know that hopefully that was a one-time
thing for us yeah when you found out
that Francia was a match I mean what
goes through your head and you are I
know that you're so close to her I see
her commenting on your Instagram and
vice-versa and you know that she's a
close family friend the thing that was
interesting is how we actually met
Francia is I recall her she was one of
the first people that was not part of
the channel that introduced herself to
Celina and made her feel comfortable
like the Teen Choice Awards I remember
the moment I met Francie and I can't
tell you the moment I met a lot of
people right and and so I really - like
literally where it was and and I'm in so
that was just really strange how I think
things lining she walked up and she
introduced herself she was on the the
ABC show hmm and um and so she was
already established and everything and
she just walked up Selena often gave her
a hug and made her really welcomed and
that resonated with me because it's such
a tough industry that you don't really
get that a lot especially among
announcements about young women and and
Mean Girls but I feel like this industry
does lend itself to that and so to know
that she was so open and had such a good
heart mhm yeah it does mean something
yeah you remember it for sure yeah yeah
we have a bunch of questions coming in
so we're gonna take some of them lots of
folks are saying how much they loved the
show Thank You T on YouTube says do you
love season one or season two of
thirteen reasons why better um I can you
really comment on it when it's your baby
yeah it's like you know it's a it's a
different it's their different you know
there's totally different story so I
think for both of their own individual
journeys and what they tried to do I
think they kind of have a special place
in my heart forever because it it exists
at all so I know that there have been
some talks of season three already Brian
Yorkie said something about it where do
you see the show going anyway I didn't I
don't know if that's a question I get
like yeah okay to be honest because
there's so many places for it to go
actually and I think Brian is like it's
mustard in his brain so I you know I
definitely feel like we can always
explore more yeah but I don't know it's
it's it's quiet that's a that's a tricky
one you know do you think that there's a
place for Catherine Langford in season
three because so much of this season was
about clay letting Hannah go I mean I
personally as like someone who thinks
creatively I wouldn't think I feel it
would be forced okay but I mean it's
Catherine you know is so amazing but if
we want to do you know storytelling I'm
yeah I don't know you know it's like I
don't know where would we wouldn't feel
force sure you know and she's gonna be
fine yeah she's so talented
she's amazing amazing I mean we couldn't
have been more more lucky to have found
her yeah I would love to see more about
where clay goes from that final scene
yeah he wasn't uses brilliant yeah yeah
phenomenal the actors artists you just
want to see them and follow them and
know what's going on I'm gonna say
actors bring so much and you just like
you love them we just were so lucky I
mean it was a lot of effort from
everybody to find the right cast yeah so
it wasn't just luck we didn't find them
all right away but you know it was it
was a huge cast to feel and to be able
to get such a talented ensemble that
truly cares and it was not about like
career-changing for them it was about
really getting out the message and
honoring these characters it was you
know to the point to where we're like
okay take a break like you know they
were just so amazing yeah how do you
balance everything between this show and
the production company I know you have
an almost five-year-old daughter you
have Selena you have your husband I mean
what is the secret oh there's no it's
literally it's like you have to just
take a break and go shut yourself up and
make the break happen it is it's it's
challenging but I have like a great
employees at my company and my husband
is a great father and he's like so
involved and he has great in place we
have a good support system and um we I
wish we had a nanny like like someone
that we always knew that was like there
but we don't we we do try to juggle it
you know ourselves but yeah it's it's a
challenge I I guess you just you do it
yeah and you figure it out and then you
just make things priority so and know
that like you don't have to do
everything so that's a like like why I'm
so selective of what I put my heart and
passion into because I'm gonna put my
all into it
yeah and when people were telling us
while back when we were just like with
Selena at the beginning stages and
guiding her career that we should manage
other people I was like I don't know
that I can because I only know how to do
it from a mother's perspective and so
everything to me is from a mother's
perspective and you can become like you
know my nickname is mama bear on the
show and so like and and that's amongst
the writer yeah it's like it becomes you
take it on so I think it's just like
making sure you only do what you feel
like is the priority in that moment
right now well then seen how dark but
also how incredible this industry can be
in seeing what Salinas navigated and
gone through would you ever let Gracie
follow in her footsteps I would prefer
that she be the vet she's talking about
being all the time that yet she is also
quite entertaining and quite the
storyteller and you know she's around it
all the time you know because my husband
manages a lot of the mall he had mostly
musicians and then he has a couple other
like talent but so she's she goes to
sets and like doesn't know she knows not
to like talk and then she'll go you know
into concerts and you know watch the
artist performing so she's around it so
it's kind of her everyday and um I I
will support her but I you know I don't
know if I could do around to Selena's
been in it since I mean Barney yeah
that's a long time a long time now
do you ever regret it or are you so
happy to see the career longevity that
she's had no I mean I don't I don't
think I regret anything yeah I feel like
she wanted it she wanted to do it yeah
so I supported her and you know Barney
was just in our small town and you know
she it's a I think you're destined to do
what you're what you do and that some
for her to be picked out of that in line
next to demo you know less which is like
then both like oh go like down Disney or
whatever it's like ya had Disney not did
their world search I don't know that we
would be here but there was a reason why
that happened and so it's like I feel
like she would have done it at 18 or you
know whenever yeah if it was in her and
so I just kind of supported and really
not expecting it was for me whenever her
and Amy would actually
practice the Disney Channel saying that
when they've way before and they like hi
Anna and so the day she filmed hers I
got teary-eyed because I remember them
doing that with like the glow necklaces
yeah and they were like do it and like
they would cut the glow stick open so
it's all in my car like you know all the
good stuff everywhere and the whole car
would just be like you know luckily I
stuff doesn't stain yeah they were just
like doing that so that was like you
know moments like that was like wow this
is kind of incredible what a memory yeah
yeah it's so magical is it weird for you
to have been pulled into all the
headline hoopla there's been a lot out
there about your guys's relationship
today can you set that straight for us I
don't see why I'm relevant like you know
it's like I am out here doing if you
like follow like her career hmm
I really don't do interviews unless it's
for charity or like something important
like this is important to me yeah and
you know this will probably won't happen
on all of my projects and but yeah it
it's what I don't what I don't like
about it even for the celebrities
themselves that get like wrapped in that
is what people don't realize is that
everyone out here they're people too and
they can make things Messier you know
like my own reality shows like when you
see most of those families fall apart
yep they barely make it through because
the world is now like putting their
opinion on and so that's why I like I
would never do a reality show like ever
because like I don't want it to mess
with my family because family is the
most important thing you know there is
yeah nothing else should really matter
so I I don't know why anybody cares
really about me you know like honestly
it's like a in in that sense sure and I
I just I don't really know you know why
they care in in that world I don't know
it's it's it's interesting right
it comes with the territory I guess you
know but you know and I think it's just
because people care so much about your
family and they want to know that you
guys are okay and that Hollywood hasn't
affected the dynamic I mean you guys
obviously work so well together and you
found this amazing project to do and I
think that's why the interest was out
there well that was the that was the
point of me us doing press the first
time around together because we wanted
the parents to see a parent and a child
work together on something that we want
parents and kids to talk about yeah so
that's the reason why I was kind of like
oh maybe we should do some together on
that and so that that's why otherwise I
don't really do press or media right for
anything which is why we're so glad
you're here
oh thank you no I mean it's just it's
just like you know I'm not as
interesting as people like to you know
build you up eyes oh that's an
interesting thought about me but like
you know like that happen it's like you
can't fight it it's just whatever people
put out there they put out there but you
guys are okay yeah I mean she's my
daughter
yeah like you know it's lifeline sure
it's like real life you know like it's
human yeah I mean yeah we're gonna take
a few more of these and I on YouTube
says what do you do to prevent oh this
is a heavy one what to do to prevent
suicide when you're a parent uh-oh that
is a heavy question anyone that's why we
made the show um I think it's just I
don't think it's um I don't think that
you will blame yourself for that you
know happening if it does happen I just
think the only thing you can do is just
try to monitor little signs and pay
attention more to what kind of goes on
to your in your kids world what's going
on in culture and society because you
know like we do tons of research for the
show and know what's going on
and there's still things like we were
talking out there that I didn't know
exist yeah so the pressure that our this
generation is in I just feel like being
as active you know as you can in your
kid's life and as much as they'll let
you in that they're there is really
strictly no one clue you know and I mean
obviously if they're saying it that's a
huge red flag but if it can come out of
nowhere yeah I mean and it's sad so pay
attention it's just it's just paying
attention I mean you can't I don't think
anybody can prevent mm-hmm you can do
your best to know you cared and you try
it or you paid attention but I don't if
there was we would stop every one of
them yeah you know two more questions
for you
I interviewed Selina a couple years ago
and she said that you're the one that
instilled in her her desire to give back
and to get involved with charities and
philanthropic work can you speak to that
at all I know that you still give back
and you're very involved in so many
charities I feel that giving back to me
is usually when I'm I I'm happiest
because I experienced a lot growing up
and I didn't have a lot but so I II was
put in a position you know like that the
that's when the case that the media
actually does work for you because now I
can let go be a spokesperson for a
charity or I can give back and that's
when it's you know utilize for something
so important and it's if you're given if
the whole world would like not be all
about a me space and I come from Texas
so when I was in production in Texas I
have a production company it's night and
day
yeah compare the in Texas if it was
always like what can you do what can we
do for our community and then I felt
here that was the same way we were but
then it felt like oh it's like what can
you do for me oh my eyes are floating
over here because I'm Marty you know
like you're like I don't
Phil anything's gonna happen and I'm
going okay that we were blessed to have
something and the opportunity to do that
and if I can take away someone's pain
because I know I can take it and I can
hold it I would rather do that yeah then
you know go on a vacation or whatever I
don't know it just it's important to
return the blessings because that's the
only way we're gonna make this place
better
a hundred percent speaking of
empowerment I was at Taylor Swift's
concert on Saturday when Selena got up
there and she gave this heartfelt speech
about how much she loves Taylor I'm just
curious as her mom what do you love
about that friendship um we were
actually there Friday night and so what
what I love about that that friendship
is it's so solid and and with Taylor I
feel like they can tell each other
anything and like it will be an honest
like in your best interest kind of
relationship yeah it's not about
anything else and you really it's like
one you just don't find out here and
it's like she's what with Taylor you see
with you what you see is what you get
she is who she is and and that's why
like she's so grounded and what worked
so hard and she's always been there for
Selena and and it's you just it's so
hard to find someone who and it's kind
of the same audience and you know and
it's so cutthroat right now that they're
they came kind of I mean Taylor I think
had already really been in a different
level when they met but they come up
together and they just have never parted
so to me that's like a true friendship I
could not agree more yeah it's just a
true friendship
I met Taylor on Saturday and I got the
same feeling I was like you're exactly
how I picture you to be and I'm so I
love watching that friendship so much
yeah yeah it is it was really cute
because Gracie when Gracie was born
Taylor bought her like boxes of clothes
like the you know that and they were all
like that all these clothes and they got
sent and so when Gracie went backstage
to talk to her Gracie had bought her
about a bun to give him back and
probably but okay so and she bear in
mind she kept saying what was I supposed
to say yeah yeah
that's so sweet though in such a
testament to you as a mom that she
wanted to do that yeah yeah really
yeah well thank you so much for being
here and for being so open and for
talking about this show before we wrap
up maybe one reason why you think people
should watch the series in the season
two because I feel like even I working
on the show I get something from it yeah
so it's like as we're creating the the
project things to me and like I'm like
oh oh my gosh like I've done that I did
that it's just to maybe even reflect
self reflect or if you're concerned
about someone educate yourself on the
different ways and you know check out
the resources that the show gives them
100 yeah percent make sure you guys
watch those PSAs and yeah there are a
lot of resources
mhm well thank you so much for being
here thank you guys for watching make
sure that you follow up with her or
follow her on social media kicked to the
curb productions right just Instagram
nothing else I mean yeah yes but she
will respond which is amazing um and
thank you guys for watching we'll see
you next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]